that final battle between ray and and
kylo Ren with those massive waves seeing
that on an IMAX screen it's pretty
spectacular say the most valuable lesson
that Poe has taught me is the difference
between being a soldier and a leader
it's one thing to feel that you have the
answer and do everything you can't to
prove that and it's another thing to
take a moment breathe listen to the
ladies follow their advice and and learn
how to how to think think more for the
group when I think about rises Skywalker
and and the shooting of that film
filming it with my friends with John and
Daisy and JJ and Anthony Daniels in
particular and being out in the Wadi Rum
desert in Jordan how spectacular that
place was we just had so much fun every
day and and I'll definitely miss that I
have to go with Yavin if I was gonna
live on any location five seven five
I forget which Yavin it is but it's a
great Yavin it's uh it's got the
pyramids because it was in the original
Star Wars it's the the period pyramids
of Tikal what they - all right I was
born about IMAX is probably the best way
to see it I would think it's just it'll
be a fully immersive experience the film
itself is just so massive and
overwhelming and to see what so many
incredible people have created and see
it on that big scale I think is gonna be
really impressive
[Music]
you